avec murs de fresnes on ne vous
demandera pas de couper votre téléphone
bien au contraire les spectateurs et
comme un narrateur la compagnie m'avait
loca vous fait vivre de l'intérieur le
quotidien des résistants enfermé en 39
[Musique]
c'est la question du choix
à l'époque c'était la question du choix
quel toit faisait ton bac l import ce
mais de quel bord quel bord choisissent
et on est ce qu'on dit souvent que les
français ont été très résistant mais en
fait ils ont été massivement à partir de
quel épisode va suivre en fonction du
vote que vous allez effectuer parce
qu'il ya plusieurs mots qui relie
plusieurs épisodes des mots clés comme
amour tortures arrestations
régulièrement vous pouvez aussi
interagir directement sur le plateau
donc à l'encan jacquot n'aimiez se fait
interroger on peut c'est le public qui
décide de lui donner des coups cinq
personnages sont actuellement créer des
personnages réels louis jaconelli
hughette proulx ni robert beck gaston
daoust et berty albrecht la compagnie ma
belle octobre a entrepris un long
travail de recherche avec un point de
départ mur de fresnes du journaliste
henri calet qui publié en 1945 qui est
un livre absolument étonnant qui compile
tous les graffitis qui ont été laissées
par les prisonniers au départ des
allemands pendant l'occupation pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale dont ouvrage
m'a d'abord donné un certain nombre de
graffitis et des indications sur quel
type de personnes avaient été arrêtées
et quel avait été leur destin et à
partir de ce fou de tous ces noms là
j'ai fait mon propre choix à l'intérieur
et j'ai fait des recherches
supplémentaires pour voir qu'il est
qu'elle avait été l'histoire de ces
personnes et qu'est ce qu'il en reste
est une immersion prenantes porté par un
seul comédien mur de frêne est encore en
cours de création avec l'ajout de deux
autres personnages avant d'être portés
sur scène